we had a few cases less than 10 cases on
our campus we did what we knew it was
best which was to be proactive and
mascot our campus covered restrictions
back in some places they are and on many
campuses unnecessary coveted rules never
went away like the roughly 70 colleges
that still have vaccine mandates for
students so what's the point of all this
well schools say these policies are
necessary to keep students safe that
doesn't reflect the risk covid actually
poses to young people College age adults
generally aren't at risk for severe
coveted complications the evidence for
masks as a coveted precaution was always
flimsy and it's increasingly clear that
in practice they offer very little
protection young adults and everyone
else should be free to make their own
decisions about the risks of coronavirus
with an absurd insistence on safety over
everything it seems like college
administrators can help but treat their
students like children